these were the scenes that many in
Brazil had feared for months thousands
of supporters a former president
storming the heart of government
Congress the Supreme Court and the
presidential Palace
once inside they ran Riot shattering
windows and destroying furniture
calls to action had begun on social
media the moment the new president
Silva was sworn in just a week ago
Lula who was 800 kilometers away in the
state of Sao Paulo blamed his
predecessor for inciting the attack
everybody knows that this was encouraged
by several speeches made by the former
president he encouraged the invasion of
the Supreme Court of the presidential
Palace he encouraged the invasion of the
three governmental Powers whenever he
could this is also his responsibility
and is the responsibility of the parties
that supported him all this will be
investigated forcefully and very quickly
oh Sonata supporters have been camping
outside military Barracks across Brazil
since Lula defeated bolsonaro in last
year's presidential election
they refused to accept the results
making unfounded claims the voting
system was rigged and accusing the
Supreme Court of bias
two months they have been calling for
military intervention to stop Lula from
taking office when that didn't happen
they took matters into their own hands
police in Brasilia were slow to act
raising questions about their loyalties
many members of Brazil's security forces
have been strong supporters of bolsonaro
world leaders have condemned the
violence and rallied behind Lula U.S
President Joe Biden called the attack
outrageous and pledged his government's
full support
by Sunday evening Security Forces had
regained control of the buildings and
the federal government will be in charge
of security in the capital until the end
of the month
but the challenge to the new
Administration is far from over
bolsonaro supporters across the country
say they'll take to the streets until
they topple the government a promise
that is leaving the president's vision
of a United Brazil more distant than
ever Monica and Al Jazeera Rio de
Janeiro